[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Christian
Siebers guten Abend ihnen allen der
Donnerschlag aus Karlsruhe halt nach und
er wirkt vielleicht sogar erst richtig
heute als der Berliner Politik klar wird
so wie das Bundesverfassungsgericht der
Bundesregierung ein Milliardenloch in
ihren Haushalt reißt das ist nicht nur
eine Finanzfrage das ist eine politische
und auch eine ganz grundsätzliche für
dieses Land und sie könnte diese
Koalition erheblich ins Wanken bringen
denn nach dem Urteil gibt es eine Menge
politischer Verlierer in der Regierung
ich rede gleich mit dem Oppositionschef
erst die Frage wie geht's jetzt weiter
Buchwald und der Tag
danach Berlin wie gelämt es geht um den
Haushalt fürs nächste Jahr alles kein
Problem sagt die Koalition das Urteil
betreffe ja nur den klimafond viele aber
Ahnen seit gestern gelten neue Regeln
zur gleichen Zeit im Plenarsaal aktuelle
Stunde auf Antrag der Union solo für den
Oppositionsführer sie kommen jetzt nicht
mehr um hin zu akzeptieren dass sie die
Prioritäten ihres Haushaltes unseres
Haushaltes der Bundes s ne Orden müssen
fangen Sie damit so früh wie möglich an
die SPD aber kon sofort das ist jetzt
die Stunde der besser Wisser und ne klug
und ne klug jetzt regiert der Rotstift
wo aber wird gespart längst toben die
Verteilungskämpfe ein ist meiner
Fraktion ein ist der Ampel völlig klar
Klimaschutz und sozialer Zusammenhalt
dürfen nicht die Verlierer sein es um
die Zukunft der Wirtschaft sagen die
Grünen Industrie im
rgebiet 2 Milliarden Euro für die
Förderung von tüsseng GRP um dem
Unternehmen zu ermöglichen künftig
klimaneutralen Stahl zu produzieren
zurecht völlig zurecht hat der
Ministerpräsident Nordrhein Westfalens
Hendrik wüst damals diese einzigartige
Chance Jobs für die Zukunft zu sichern
gefeiert woher aber soll das Geld nun
kommen keine höheren Steuern sagt der
Minister und keine neuen Schulden
wirerden Geld wirksamere Politik machen
müssen als im vergangenen Jahrzehnt sie
wollten Herr Finanzminister den
Transformation den Klima und
transformationsfor als Allzweckwaffe als
Steinbruch einsetzen er ist zum
Rohrkrepierer geworden das ist doch die
Wahrheit hier solche Rohrkrepierer
jedoch könnten durchaus auch anderen
drohen rechnet die FDP vor die
unionsgeführte Landesregierung in
Nordrheinwestfalen hat gleich nach ihrem
Regierungswechsel ein Ukraine
Sondervermögen Milliarden schwer
aufgelegt und sie finanziert daraus
jetzt per Übertragung unter anderem
Förderung der Energieeffizienz in
Krankenhäusern die Opposition ganz
rechts und ganz links will immer schon
gewusst haben dass die Regierung falsch
rechne Kanzler und Kabinett regierten
mit ungedeckten Schecks Milliarden für
Intel zugesagt was passiert denn jetzt
mit den Milliarden für Intel gibt die
die Investition in die Bahn passieren
die jetzt wirdern eine nesetzung eines
als proess ist 24 unter Anrechnung der
Kredite der Sondervermögen auf die
Schuldenbremse davon jedoch wollen sie
im Haushaltsausschuss bisher nichts
wissen Sie beraten noch immer rechnen
hin und her gerade so als sein nichts
geschehen woher aber die 60 Milliarden
kommen sollen die jetzt fehlen weiß
keiner so genau gerade haben wir in im
Bundestag gesehen jetzt ist er live bei
uns der Oppositionsführer Friedrich märz
seine CDU CSU Fraktion hatte ja in
Karlsruhe geklagt guten Abend Herr März
guten Abend her fühlen Sie sich als
na ja also für
Triumph ist das kein Urteil sondern das
ist ein Urteil das uns alle betrifft das
gilt ja auch nicht nur für diese
Wahlperiode das wird wahrscheinlich auch
für viele Bundesländer gelten aber das
diszipliniert jetzt den
Haushaltsgesetzgeber und deswegen werden
wir über vieles neu reden müssen gehen
wir es vielleicht mal durch Industrie
und Handwerk sehen zum Teil jetzt mit
Schrecken was das
Bundesverfassungsgericht ihnen da
eingebrockt hat die Unionsfraktion
letztlich ihn eingebrockt hat wenn die
Finanznot jetzt die Politik lähmt und
diese dringende Transformation die das
Land ja braucht verhindert könnte es
dann am Ende auch nur Verlierer
geben Sie was eingebrockt hat uns dass
weder das Bundesverfassungsgericht noch
die Opposition eingebrockt hat sich dass
diese Regierung selbst die gegen alle
Ratschläge im letzten Jahr einen
Nachtragshaushalt für das vorletzte Jahr
beschlossen hat und Schulden übertragen
hat hat die für Corona vorgesehen waren
und die jetzt in diesen Klima und
transformationsfond gesteckt werden
sollten das ist verfassungswidrig das
ist nichtig also von Anfang an unwirksam
und daraus muss die Bundesregierung
jetzt die richtigen Schlussfolgerungen
ziehen eine Schlussfolgerung wäre
gewesen zu sagen wir stoppen das
laufende Haushaltsverfahren und klären
mal woher denn das Geld kommen soll dass
sie für das nächste Jahr alle schon
zugesagt haben sie haben wir gerade
selbst gesagt es reicht weit in die
Zukunft bindet letztlich nicht nur diese
Regierung sie nehme ich jetzt einfach
mal an wollen ja immer noch Kanzler
werden dann trifft das ja auch sie dass
ihnen irgendwann mal das Geld fehlen
sollte falls die Kanzler würden um ihre
Pläne umzusetzen ich habe das genauso in
der letzten Bundestagssitzung
bundestagsfraktionssitzung bei uns
gestern Mittag gesagt wir hatten eine
Sondersitzung der Bundestagsfraktion ich
habe den Kolleginnen und Kollegen genau
das gesagt das bindet auch uns das
diszipliniert uns jetzt und jetzt müssen
wir mal in Deutschland mit 1000
Milliarden Euro Steuereinnahmen
auskommen so viel Steuereinnahmen werden
wir nämlich im nächsten Jahr haben das
heißt also wir müssen jetzt wirklich
Prioritäten setzen und das wäre auch
unser Anspruch an die Bundesregierung
ich habe der Bundesregierung angeboten
ihr dabei auch zu helfen indem wir jetzt
ein Haushaltsverfahren beginnen indem
diese Verpflichtungen abgebildet werden
sie haben gerade die Beiträge der
Kollegen eingeblendet genau diese
Ausgaben sind geplant aber sie sind vom
Haushalt 2024 nicht gedeckt die
Koalition berät diesen Haushalt als ob
die Entscheidung von gestern nicht
gegeben hätte und daran werden wir nun
sicherlich nicht mitwirken jetzt stehen
aber ganz wichtige Investitionen auf der
kppe also Investitionen in die Bahn in
solar und Wind in Infrastruktur und
wasserstoffnetze vieles von dem was ja
auch sie unterstützen und was das ist
glaube ich unstrittig dieses Land
tatsächlich braucht jetzt haben sie
gesagt das müssen Prioritäten gesetzt
werden was wären denn da ihre
Prioritäten auf was wä als erstes zu
verzichten also ich sage mal ganz
konkret die Kindergrundsicherung bringt
für keine Familie und für kein Kind
Verbesserungen gibt aber 500 Millionen
Euro aus für neue Bürokratie und schafft
3000 neue Stellen im öffentlichen Dienst
das wäre mal ein klares Signal der
Koalition dass sie jetzt wirklich etwas
verändern will aber sie tut es nicht so
wir machen konkrete Vorschläge sie
lehnen sie alle ab und deswegen muss die
Regierung jetzt mal diesen Weg zunächst
alleine gehen ich sage voraus das geht
wieder in die Richtung eines
verfassungswidrigen Bundeshaushaltes
Herz aber um alleine diese riesige
Transformation Richtung Klima
Neutralität für Deutschland für dieses
Industrieland zu schaffen wäre so viel
Geld möglich dass um das zu nötig um das
zu finanzieren werden dermaßene
Einschnitte in in das soziale Netz nötig
dass auch die CDU CSU die nicht
mittragen würde also mit Millionen die
Sie gerade genannt haben wird das ja
nicht gehen kriegen wir das Land ja
nicht auf V gebracht ne das wird in der
Tat so einfach nicht gehen aber wenn
eine Bundesregierung den
haushaltsprozess für das Jahr 2024 ind
dem das Geld fehlt jetzt ungeniert und
ungehindert weiter fortsetzt dann können
Sie von uns nicht ernsthaft erwarten
dass wir jetzt auf der Grundlage dieses
Haushaltes noch Sparvorschläge machen
wie man denn die zusätzlichen ich sag
mal für das Jahr 2024 geschätzten 20
Milliarden Euro finanzieren kann da muss
die Bundesregierung jetzt sagen wir
setzen das Haushaltsverfahren neu auf
und dann machen wir auch sehr konkrete
Vorschläge was man tun könnte was ist
mit dem sogenannten doppelwums des
Bundeskanzlers also den 200 Milliarden
das ja noch ganz andere Summe als die
die aktuelle im Raum steht für die
energiepreisbremsen auch das sei jetzt
in Frage gestellt sagt ihr fieze
Matthias Middelberg heute werden sie
tatsächlich auch daran sägen und die
Regierung quasi auch auf dem Gebiet
schachmat setzen am Ende ich habe heute
ein Rechtsgutachten in Auftrag gegeben
um festzustellen ob die Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts die gestern
verkündet worden ist nicht nur für den
Klima und transformationsfond sondern
auch für den den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond gilt ich
rechne damit dass ich in der nächsten
Woche Ende nächster Woche spätestens
anfang übernächster Woche ein erstes
Ergebnis habe und darauf auf dieser
Grundlage werde ich dann die
Entscheidung treffen ob wir auch gegen
den WSF nach karzruh gehen
aha und das dann eventuell auch zu
kippen in Karlsruhe da warten Sie aber
noch ab haben sie noch keine endgültige
Entscheidung getroffen haben sie gesagt
Entscheidung treffen wir wenn es soweit
ist ein anderer Punkt der noch wichtig
ist 10 Milliarden für die intelabrik in
Magdeburg wir haben es gerade kurz
gehört im im Beitrag die sind jetzt auch
völlig offen weil nicht finanziert hat
sich ihr CDU Parteifreund der lokale
Ministerpräsident denn schon bei Ihnen
gemeldet und gesagt danke für nichts wir
werden mit den Ministerpräsidenten der
unionsgeführten Bundesländer in den
nächsten Tagen darüber beraten es
betrifft auch die Bundesländer aber
eines ist auch klar so wie die
Bundesregierung Haushaltspolitik macht
verfassungswiedrig kann es nicht
weitergehen wir sprechen hier übrigens
her siers auch über Schulden die unsere
Kinder und unsere Enkelkinder irgendwann
mal zurückzahlen müssen und deswegen
sprechen wir auch hier von nachhaltiger
Finanzpolitik die der Bundesregierung
ist es nicht sagt der Oppositionsführer
Friedrich März ich danke Ihnen für das
Gespräch Herr Merz ich danke
Ihnen und damit zu unserem nächsten
Thema heute Abend die Fragen aus aller
Welt werden drängender und sie richten
sich an israels Regierung und
Militärführung das ausgerechnet ein
Krankenhaus im Zentrum heftiger Kämpfe
in den letzten Tagen stand das Israels
Armee ausgerechnet ein Krankenhaus mit
Soldaten stürmt die dort von Station zu
Station gehen hat die Regierung immer
damit erklärt dass Hamas mit voller
Absicht direkt unter dem Krankenhaus ihr
weit verzweigtes Hauptquartier in
Tunnelanlagen eingerichtet habe viel
hängt jetzt davon ab ob Israel dafür
wirklich Beweise präsentieren kann
wichtig zu wissen im schifah Krankenhaus
sind nach unoangaben immer noch etwa
2300 Menschen darunter kranke verletzte
und medizinisches Personal das aushart
und versucht ohne ausreichend Energie
Wasser und Medikamente irgendwie
weiterzumachen augenzeugen berichten von
schrecklichen Zuständen und Toten die
nicht beerdigt werden können Henriette
de
mier ein letzter gemeinsamer Augenblick
der
Stille allah ist groß rufen Sie im Süden
des gaserstreifens trauern Palästinenser
um 28 tote Menschen die heute bei einem
Luft Angriff der israelischen Armee
umgekommen sein sollen ob und wie viele
hamaskämpfer darunter sind
ungewiss auch heute keine Feuerpause
Israel greift weiter an vergangene Nacht
brachten Soldaten der israelischen Armee
auch den Hafen von gazastadt unter ihre
Kontrolle wie diese Bilder des
israelischen Militärs zeigen sollen im
vermeintlich sicheren Süden von Gaza
fehlen heute Flugblätter vom Himmel
abgeworfen von der israelischen Armee
sie fordert die Menschen auf ihre
Unterkünfte zu
verlassen israel hatte die Menschen
aufgefordert nach Süden zu gehen das
haben wir gemacht jetzt sagen Sie wir
sollen wiedergehen aber wohin wir
möchten verstehen wo genau wir hin
sollen es ist vorbei wir können nicht
mehr der Punkt Null ist erreicht ich
habe Angst nicht nur um mich selbst ich
habe Angst um meine
Kinder zur Angst kommt Verlorenheit
kommt Hunger die humanitäre Lage der
Menschen im ifen verschlechtert sich
zusehens die Kinder haben Hunger und
Durst sie leiden unter Durchfall
übergeben sich und haben
Husten Versorgung Unterkünfte
Krankenhäuser alles schon jetzt längst
am
Limit das gesamte medizinische Personal
arbeitet unter sehr großem Druck wir
müssen uns um die Verletzten kümmern und
jetzt auch noch um die Menschen die aus
den nördlichen Regionen vertrieben
wurden
auch heute im kibutz beri wo die Hamas
Terroristen am 7 Oktober am schlimmsten
wüteten der israelische Außenminister
führt EU-Vertreter durch das was
Menschen einmal Heimat war darunter auch
der Außenbeauftragte der Mahn Israel
dürfe sich verteidigen dürfe die
palästinensische Zivilbevölkerung jedoch
nicht
vergessen ich verstehe eure Wut aber
lasst mich euch bitten euch nicht von
der Wut auf zu lassen sich von der Wut
nicht aufzehren lassen heute Abend wurde
bekannt dass die 65-Jährige Judit weiß
aus dem
kibutberi Tot ist sie war eine der
Verschleppten Geiseln ihre Leiche wurde
nahe des Krankenhaus als Schiefer in
gazastadt von israelischen Soldaten
gefunden und weitere Nachrichten jetzt
im Überblick und den hast du
Gund nach einer schwierigen Phase wollen
die us USA und China ihre Beziehungen
wieder verbessern und dafür enger
zusammenarbeiten bei ihrem ersten
persönlichen Treffen seit einem Jahr
demonstrierten die Präsidenten beiden
und Ski Einigkeit als Durchbruch wird
gewertet dass sie vereinbarten direkte
militärische Kontakte wieder
einzurichten größter Streitpunkt bleibt
allerdings der Status von Taiwan auf das
China Ansprüche erhebt beiden warnte
Peking vor militärischen Aktivitäten
der neue britische Außenminister Cameron
hat bei seiner ersten Auslandsreise der
Ukraine weitere Unterstützung
zugesichert in Kiev sagte er Präsident
selenski diplomatische humanitäre und
vor allem militärische Hilfen zu soangee
wie nötig selenski zeigte sich dankbar
für diese Geste während des Krieges im
Nahen Osten der die Aufmerksamkeit von
dem russischen Krieg gegen die Ukraine
ablenke die russischen ffe dort dauern
an und verursachen weiter große Schäden
Pedro Sanchez bleibt Ministerpräsident
Spaniens und kann seine linke Regierung
fortsetzen das Parlament hat den
51-Jährigen Sozialisten im Amt bestätigt
seine Wiederwahl war umstritten denn für
die notwendigen Stimmen hatte Sanchez
katalanischen Parteien Zugeständnisse
machen müssen darunter eine Amnestie für
katalanische unabhängigkeits worte gegen
diese Straffreiheit protestierten auch
heute wieder tausende
Spanier mit einer großratah in sieben
Bundesländern sind die
Sicherheitsbehörden gegen das islamische
Zentrum Hamburg vorgegangen
Innenministerin fäer erklärte der Verein
stehe im Verdacht sich gegen die
verfassungsgemäße Ordnung zu richten
außerdem soll er Aktivitäten der
proiranischen hisbolla aus dem Libanon
unterstützen der Verfassung Schutz stuft
die Vereinigung als islamistisch ein zu
ihr gehört auch die Blaue Moschee in
Hamburg Landwirte in der EU dürfen den
umstrittenen Unkrautvernichter Glyphosat
für Zeh weitere Jahre einsetzen die
Entscheidung traf die EU-Kommission
unmittelbar nachdem sich Vertreter der
EU-Staaten in einem berufungsausschuss
zum Thema nicht hatten einigen können
Glyphosat steht im Verdacht
krebserregend zu sein und es gibt
Bedenken bezüglich der Gefahren für die
Umwelt auch deshalb hat die Kommission
neue Bedingungen und Einschränkungen für
die Verwendung des Mittels
beschlossen seit vier Stunden ist der
Bahnstreik offiziell vorbei morgen soll
der Betrieb wieder normal laufen was die
bahnh halt unter Normal versteht weitere
Streiks schließt Klaus weselski der Chef
der lockführergewerkschaft allerdings
nicht aus wenn man sich die Positionen
im Tarifstreit so anguckt dann kann man
auch sagen sie sind wohl
wahrscheinlich die Kommentare der
Reisenden heute jedenfalls
unterschiedlich die einen unterstützen
die Forderungen nach mehr Lohn und
weniger Arbeitszeit im Schichtbetrieb
die anderen sind genervt und haben dafür
wenig Verständnis und dann gibt's noch
die Spaßvögel die meinen Streik und
Normalbetrieb seinen bei der Deutschen
Bahn ohnehin nicht zu unterscheiden
senvenja domeierer berichtet Julian rab
ist loogführer und liebt seinen Job
trotz Schichtdienst regelmäßiger
Überstunden und nicht gerade üppiger
Bezahlung zwischen 2700 und 3800 € broto
liegt das Gehalt eines lockführers zum
Job gehört auch immer wieder Patzer und
Pannen der Bahn zu erklären es ist
natürlich nicht nur Knöpfchen drücken
das muss man ganz klar sagen wir haben
mit vielen Störungen zu tun man kommt
auch manchmal an so ein Punkt das System
wird immer komplexer und es fällt mir
schon manchmal schwer herunterzubrechen
für die Fahrgäste woran liegt es jetzt
eigentlich im Kampf um bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen legt heute die
Gewerkschaft GDL den Bahnverkehr lahm
konkret fordert sie bei 12 Monaten
Laufzeit mindestens 555 € mehr im Monat
sowie eine Erhöhung der Zulagen für
Schichtarbeit um
25% plus steuerfreie inflationszahlung
von 3000 € das wichtigste aber 35 statt
38 Stunden wöchentliche Arbeitszeit bei
vollem
Lohnausgleich seit 10 Jahren wird
diskutiert wir zu wenig Lockführer haben
jetzt haben wir zu wenig zugbekleiter
jetzt haben wir keine Fahrdienstleiter
mehr jetzt sind die Mitarbeiter in der
Werkstatt knapp wir nehmen also W dass
die Menschen die Berufe nicht mehr als
attraktiv genug empfinden jetzt kommt's
seit Jahrzehnten haben die Arbeitgeber
keine Idee und die GDL entwickelt eine
und sagt wir müssen die Arbeitszeit ein
kürzen und dadurch das Leben attraktiver
machen mit weniger Wochenstunden mehr
personalgewinnen daran glaubt man bei
der Bahn nicht im Fall einer Verkürzung
der Arbeitszeit müsse das Unternehmen
10000 Stellen neu besetzen so eine
Studie des Instituts der deutschen
Wirtschaft bei der derzeitigen Lage auf
dem Arbeitsmarkt eine Unmöglichkeit sagt
die Bahn wenn wir diese Forderung
erfüllen würden würden nicht nur die
Personalkosten exorbitant steigen
sondern auch der Personalbedarf um 10 %
das ist einfach nicht realistisch in der
ersten Verhandlungsrunde bietet die
Deutsche Bahn 11% mehr Lohn sowie eine
inflationsprämie von bis zu
2850 € bei einer Laufzeit von 32 Monaten
über die Arbeitszeit will sie nicht
verhandeln dabei taucht die Forderung
auch in anderen Branchen auf so kämpft
die IG Metall gerade für weniger
Wochenstunden und die vier Tage Woche
die Verhandlungen dazu laufen noch will
die Bahnmitarbeiter gewinnen müsse man
sich bewegen sagen auch Experten zur
Zeit sind die Arbeitsbedingungen extrem
Familien unfreundlich es gibt ganz wenig
Frauen in dem Beruf und wenn man da das
Defizit an Personal beheben will dann
muss man sich was einfallen lassen und
dazu gehört auch verringer Arbeitszeit
die Suche nach dem richtigen Weg sich
für die Zukunft aufzustellen hat bei der
Bahn gerade erst an Fahrt aufgenommen ob
man sich nächste Woche wieder an den
Verhandlungstisch setzt ließen heute
beide Seiten
offen so jetzt sowas wie eine
dauernachricht diese Woche Siemens
nämlich beschäftigt uns auch heute
gundulla an der Börse waren die Aktien
von Siemens heute das Zugpferd denn der
Industrie und technikkonzern legte
positive Geschäftszahlen vor einen
Rekord Gewinn von 8,5 Milliarden Euro
das beste Ergebnis in der Siemens
Geschichte die Konzernspitze bekannte
sich zudem zum Standort Deutschland und
verwies auf Investitionen in hiesige
Werke von über einer Milliarde Euro
trotz schwieriger Bedingungen plant ein
weiteres Unternehmen eine
milliardeninvestition in Deutschland der
usfarmariese Eli Lilly wird im
rheinlandfelsischen allzei eine Fabrik
bauen ohne Subventionen des Bundes Frank
betmann warum baut das US-Unternehmen
seine Geschäfte gerade in Deutschland
aus na il lilli hat einen Blockbuster in
der Hinterhand ein Präparat welches
vermutlich bald schon die Zulassung auch
in Europa erhalten wird wir reden hier
von einem Medikament gegen krankhaftes
Übergewicht in den USA bereits
erfolgreich am Markt und jetzt so heißt
es aus Insiderkreisen sollen eben dafür
auch in Europa die
Produktionskapazitäten hochgefahren
werden Lil nach zahlreichen
Forschungserfolgen mittlerweile zu den
wertvollsten Pharmaunternehmen der Welt
mit einem Börsenwert von rund 580
Milliarden Dollar und hat bereits seit
den 60er Jahren einen Firmensitz in
Deutschland im hässischen badomburg und
was genau plant Lilli in
alzei ja zu den konkreten Plänen für das
neue Werk wollte sich das Unternehmen
heute noch nicht äußern nur so viiel es
soll sich dabei um eine der größten
Investitionen von ilai Lilli weltweit
handeln viele qualifizierte Fachkräfte
würden benötigt morgen wird es eine
Pressekonferenz geben
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach und
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck wollen sich
von Berlin aus ebenfalls äußern die
Bundesregierung will seit längerem den
pharmastandort Stärken die Botschaft
morgen dürfte daher lauten se her so
unattraktiv wie manche denken ist
Deutschland gar nicht vielen Dank für
die Einschätzung Frank bmann eine
Meldung vom Tennis alexander zwerf hat
sein letztes Vorrundenspiel bei den ATP
Finals in Turin verloren gegen den
Russen mitwedjev dessen Sieg morgen
gegen Carlos alkaras sowie einen eigenen
Sieg im nächsten Spiel gegen den Russen
rubliov braucht ZEV nun für den Einzug
ins
Halbfinale der renommierte Hans Joachim
friedrichspreis für Fernsehjournalismus
ist am Abend dem ZDF Kollegen Elmar
tesen verliehen worden der Leiter des
Studios Washington berichtet über die
wohl wichtigste Ordnung
der Welt mit wie die jur sagt souveräner
Sachkenntnis und scharfem Blick für die
großen Zusammenhänge Ton teilt sich den
Preis mit der Journalistin Ina Ruck die
das ARD Studio in Moskau leitet drei
ukrainische JournalistInnen wurden mit
einem Sonderpreis ausgezeichnet für ihre
Arbeit in extrem gefährlichem
Umfeld herzlichen Glückwunsch an die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn so etwas
gibt wie eine deut Seele dann hätte sie
wahrscheinlich einen Lieblingsmaler
einen der ihr aus dem Herzen spricht von
Weite und Wald und Wanderern und
Sehnsucht Kaspar David Friedrich erst im
September kommenden Jahres jährt sich
sein Geburtstag zum 250 Mal aber das
Land kann es kaum erwarten den Meister
zu feiern Ausstellungen Bildbände
Biografien in Berlin traf christat
leppler einen der dem großen
leinwandromantiker schriftstellerisch
sehr
n mehr Romantik geht nicht der Wanderer
über dem Nebelmeer Kaspar David
Friedrich ein pommerscher Sonderling zu
liebzeiten verarmt und vergessen jetzt
geehrt und
gefeiert in der Berliner Alten
Nationalgalerie hängt eines seiner
kühnsten Bilder der Mönch am me für
Bestseller Autor Florian iles der
Urknall der
Romantik heute im Jahr 2023 stehen die
Menschen ergriffen vor diesem Bild weil
man das Gefühl hast hier wird etwas
ausgedrückt was auch unserer Sinnsuche
was unserer Sehnsucht nach Geborgenheit
was unserer tiefen Sehnsucht nach Trost
entspricht der einsame Münch von 180
Kaspar David Friedrich quält sich damit
übermalt es vielfach das Bild wird immer
dunkler in dieser Zeit hatte der
gebürtige Greifswalder Schwester und
Vater verloren Friedrich ist kein Maler
für den Kopf Friedrich ich ist ein Maler
fürs Herz und als er dieses Bild
ausstellt 1810 da schlägt Goethe
entsetzt die Hände überm Kopf zusammen
es ist ihm viel zu depressiv viel zu
schwermütig in seinem buchzauber der
Stille würdigt Ilias den
stureneinzelgänger als Superstar der
Romantik Friedrich sei wieder
Nationalheiliger noch heile weltmaler
viel mehr ein Pionier des Naturschutzes
der greidefelsen auf Rügen oder auf dem
Siegler weltberühmte Motive Friedrich
malt sie 1818 nach seiner Hochzeitsreise
mit cararoline Bommer die erste Frau die
der menschenscheuekutz küsst mit 44
Jahren Friedrich hat ein Problem er kann
Landschaft zeichnen aber keine Menschen
sie hatte große Probleme mit dem
Portrait mit der Physiognomie und er hat
sich dann irgendwann da drauf verlegt
die Figuren von hinten zu zeichnen und
dann hat er die Rückenfigur erfunden die
etwas Wunderbares leistet weil hier
steht diese Frau uns im Weg eigentlich
aber sie bringt uns dazu ins Bild
einzutreten und mit ihren Augen
rauszugucken 40 Jahre arbeitet Friedrich
in desten erfolglos von Ruhm keine Spur
meine Bilder sind leider in verchiss
geraten notiert ja das Schöne an ihm ist
dass dieses Künstlerleben was so ein
schweres war ein mühsames dass das
Bilder hervorgebracht hat von solcher
Schönheit von solcher Zeitlosigkeit die
uns heute noch berühren das ist das
Wunder der Kunst nach einem Schlaganfall
malte ein letztes düsteres Bild
Meeresufer bei Mondschein nach seinem
Tod 1840 wird er vergessen erst im 20
Jahrhundert wird er wiederentdeckt der
Maler der Natur ein und Kunst ausgeatmet
hat wir können uns freuen auf 250 Jahre
Kaspar David
Friedrich so von der Romantik jetzt
zurück in die harte Wirklichkeit jetzt
Maybritt ilner und Ihre Gäste sie
diskutieren Krieg in narost immer mehr
Judenhass in Deutschland Fragezeichen
und um
0:35 ist hier wieder Zeit für unser
heute journal Update mit nasan göckdem
von uns allen hier Danke fürs Interesse
bis morgen und ihnen einen angenehmen
Abend
[Musik]
tschüss
guten Abend es ist viel los am Himmel
über Europa da gibt es sehr große Tiefs
und eher kleine Tiefs Tiefs die ganz
langsam ziehen und welche die ganz
schnell unterwegs sind wie dieses Tief
Linus das bis morgen abend schon
Richtung Südosteuropa weghuscht es
bringt aber Regen mit Schnee und vor
allen Dingen viel Wind das geht heute
Nacht los und vor allen Dingen über den
Alpengipfeln pfeift da können zum Teil
Orkanböhen dabei sein mit mehr als 117
km pro Stund Stunde schon mittags aber
lässt der Wind mehr und mehr nach und es
gibt viel Regen es können bis zu 50 l
Regen pro Quadratmeter hier im Südwesten
fallen und im schwarzwe in einigen
Staulagen sogar bis zu 90 l pro
quadrater oberhalb von etwa 600 700 m
fällt auch Schnee die Nacht ist sonst
zum Teil auch klar dann bildet sich
etwas Nebel und es wird kalt zwischen
Schleswig-Holstein und dem vogland da
sinken die Temperaturen in Richtung
Gefrierpunkt oder knapp da drunter die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 3 und 9° vor am Vormittag kann
es hier im Süden noch weiter regnen und
auch schneien ganz freundlich wird's
dagegen zwischen dem Main und der
Nordseeküste von Westen drückt schon
wieder der nächste Regen herein der
Samstag wird dank eines kleinen
zwischenhoches deutlich freundlicher am
Sonntag dann aber wird's von Westen
schon wieder regnerischer und relativ
mild und wenn Sie sich jetzt freuen wann
dann vielleicht endlich mal eine kleine
Einwinterung kommt also auf die müssen
wir noch länger warten wie sie hier am
Beispiel von Usedom sehen können die
Temperaturen gehen auf und ab und es
bleibt eher regnerisch guten Abend